The Silver Knit pattern controller is a
simple way to download stitch patterns to
your Silver/Studio
electronic knitting machine.
You can use the large, included stitch
library or create stitch patterns of your
own quickly using any
graphics design program.
This tutorial goes beyond the
basics of using this device.
For a quick overview of the basics, click
the arrow for a Knit it Now tutorial.
Included in the utility software with
the controller are many stitch patterns.
Look in your my documents, my
designs folder on your computer.
The Silver Knit folder has samples of
many file formats that it supports.
Included in the Silver Reed folder are
digitized stitch patterns based on Mylar
sheets used with the earlier machines.
Click browse and open a stitch pattern
from the library or a pattern that you've
created, and you'll see a small preview of
the design with the stitches and rows and
the knitting method shown.
The Silver Knit uses three knitting
methods, zero one, two and three.
It's based on the number of colors in your
design and it controls how the needles of
your machine are selected as you knit.
Once you've selected your pattern, it's
time to download it to the Silver Knit
controller.
This is where the fun starts.
You can customize your
stitch pattern here.
First, select your machine
The top section of this page is where you
can quickly modify your stitch pattern,
make it double wide,
reversing it, mirror it.
There's lots of options here.
in the sections below, you can control
the position of your stitch pattern for
isolated motifs and much, much more.
Let's use a little duck
pattern and play a bit.
Click the download button.
Now we'll use the upside down function,
but you can try any of the various
features and see what they do.
Tick the checkbox and click okay.
The new information will
download to the controller.
Click okay again, and we'll use the knit
button to preview our changes and there he
is.
Ducky is standing on his head.
Other options on the download screen
includes starting with the carriage on the
left.
You can control the needle
selection for easier seaming.
You can enter the pattern width.
This is not, may or may not be the
knitting with just the stitch pattern
width
you can position the design
on your knitted piece.
And you can also select a portion
of the stitch pattern to use.
For this example, we're going to
center our duck over 25 stitches.
We also want the pattern shifted over
a bit to be off center on the garment.
When we download and preview our duck
with these settings, you'll see that the
pattern controller followed
our instructions perfectly.
We have a margin on the left and our
duck is centered over the 25 stitches.
Notice that at the bottom of the
interactive knitting screen are shown the
stitches and rows in our design,
as well as the point cam positions.
It also includes a
contrasting color indicator.
For our next example.
We only want to use the flowers
at the bottom of this design.
We've already opened the bear pattern and
we've been downloaded the entire thing one
time.
We'll use the knit button again
to preview the design close up.
And you'll see that we only want those
first eight rows row one through eight of
the pattern for our new design.
Now close the knit screen and we'll
click the download button again.
On the downloads screen, we will edit the
pattern indicators section and tell the
Silver Knit utility what
rows we want to use.
Click okay.
Click knit to preview and you'll see that
it's chosen the eight rows of flowers that
we want, and these will transfer
to our knitting machine.
The Silver Knit pattern controller is
a great option for silver or a singer.
Knitters.
Check the Knit it Now learning
library for even more tutorials.